Jérémie Decerle en campagne avec Pascal
Camphin l'agriculteur pas très pressé de
voir le glyphosate interdit ni très
militant sur le bien-être animal aux
côtés d'un ancien écolo et ex-président
du WWF un choc de deux mondes l'attelage
lrem pour les européennes avaient
provoqué pas mal de raï rimes et les
voilà tous les deux élus au Parlement
européen pour Jérémy de Serres c'est une
ascension rapide qui commence avec le
syndicalisme agricole il entre jeunes
agriculteurs à l'âge de 16 ans en 2016
il est élu à la tête de ce mouvement
proche de la FNSEA une fonction qui va
lui servir de tremplin c'est dit-on lors
d'un déjeuner avec le président Macron
et le ministre de l'Agriculture qui les
repérait et que la République en marche
lui propose une place éligible sur la
liste aux Européennes cet éleveur de
charolaise est la caution rurale et
agricole de la macronie souvent accusé
de malmener le monde paysan en ralliant
Strasbourg le nouvel élu c'est donner
une première mission promouvoir une
politique agricole commune et dans
priorité les exploitations familiales à
taille humaine